je propose de parler donc de ceux de ce
combat entre féministes je le disais
donc des femmes assez d'horizon assez
divers catherine deneuve parce qu'elle
est très connu mais aussi notre amie
elisabeth laville et vie où catherine
millet ont publié donc cette chronique
dans le monde d'hier en disant attention
n'allons pas trop loin dans la
dénonciation et méfions nous du
féminisme l'udc est une forme de haine
des hommes
cette tribune a valu une réponse assez
vives des féministes qu'on peut peut
être qualifié de radical c'est chacun en
jugera notamment caroline de haas
elle était ce matin au micro d'europe 1
à chaque fois que vous banalisez où vous
déligitimer en fait ces violences là moi
je pense qu'en effet vous laisser plus
de place aux agresseurs et moins de
place aux victimes dans cette tribune
qui a été publiée dans le monde on
retrouve en gros tous les stéréotypes
toutes les idées reçues qu'on se coltine
tous les jours à la machine à café au
bureau ou dans les repas de famille vous
savez cet oncle un peu gênant qui vous
dit mais on peut plus rien dire et c'est
ça s'appelle des idées reçues
d'abord on peut dire encore beaucoup de
choses il ya encore malheureusement je
pense beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses raciste sexiste homophobe qui
peuvent être dit dans des médias ou dans
la parole publique schengen ne mangeront
vous appréciez trop pour vous réduirez
votre rôle de femme
il se trouve que vous êtes la seule
reprennent la selle sur ce plateau ce
soir donc j'ai envie de vous poser la
question est ce que vous vous avez envie
de prendre parti dans ce dans ce dans ce
débat ce que vous êtes plutôt catherine
deneuve ou ou caroline de haas refusé de
choisir mon camp et parce que je trouve
que ce sont deux caricatures et il me
semble qu'en fait la question elle est
intéressante parce qu'elle est soulevée
par des groupes de femmes donc c'est des
femmes qui parlent des heures en fait
les femmes qui parlent entre elles des
hommes qui débattent sur est ce que les
hommes sont des porcs ou est ce qu'ils
n'en sont pas et donc c'est ça qui me
semble tout à fait intéressant dans ce
débat mais je trouve que c'est un débat
qui n'est pas du tout à mon niveau et je
trouve que dans cette histoire on oublie
que chaque cas est particulier
d'ailleurs qu'on écoute karine de la
surface et frappe en elle elle fait
vraiment des amalgames en disant que ça
ressemble à ça ce type de conversation
qu'on a autour des machines à café qui
vous gêne un peu dans les repas de
famille non chaque situation et
singulière chaque fois c'est une
relation entre deux personnes qui
s'installent et qui se grippe ou pas
mais je crois qu'il faut faire confiance
à la capacité aussi qu'ont les femmes
des conduire de façon de façon à billère
intelligente et sans se sentir pour
autant profondément meurtris dans leur
dans leur chair et donc je je ne sous
estime pas le fait que les femmes
agressées se sont objectivement agressé
et se sentent meurtri par sa part cela
mais je pense que la plupart des cas
sont des cas en fait soluble entre
personnes individuelles et qui ceux qui
se sont pas bio bon niveau et est donc
je crois que ce débat est un faux débat
mais s'il fallait choisir je dirais que
je trouve ça très courageux de la part
de catherine donne avec ce groupe de 100
femmes très éclectique d'ailleurs qui
rockent grief à on a vraiment affaire à
un espèce de faux de deux groupes assez
hétérogène et bien ce soir dirigée
contre cette espèce de puritanisme en
effet et cette volonté de faire de cette
société française une société
complètement sèche et froide en fait eh
bien écoutez d'abord je pense que
caroline de haas a tort de dire que ce
sont des idées tout c'est tous des idées
reçues il ya 20 ans j'étais à new york
je vais dîner chez des amis
là une avocate extrêmement sympathique
et on s'entend bien pendant le dîner et
elle me dit où êtes vous logez je lui
dis elle me dire je passe devant je peux
vous ramener très volontiers on descend
et dans le hall je lui tiens la porte et
je m'arrête pour la laisser passer
il me dit vous savez que je pourrais
vous poursuivre pour ça c'était une
plaisanterie mais ça ne l'était pas
complètement c'est à dire si elle avait
était autre chose que ce qu'elle était
elle aurait pu en effet se poursuivre
pour une aide pour une attitude il n'a
rien fait d'autre que lui tient la porte
rien sans le consentement de toutes les
parties ou pas mais c'est à dire ça
m'avait évidemment frappé au point que
je n'ai pas oublié et que on voit bien
le genre de vie que ça a quel sens
conduirait si on était là dedans
cela dit c'est pas pour moi l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que qu'est ce qu'on
cherche à travers cette réflexion sur
les attitudes des hommes à l'égard des
femmes depuis la sphère de einstein on
cherche à essayer de faire en sorte
d'améliorer les choses et de les
améliorer le plus loin possible
il ya des gens qui dans cette
perspective apporte des éléments de
réflexion et sur ce plan-là la tribune
de ces 100 femmes en effet très
éclectique m'a paru apporter des
éléments de réflexion y compris des
éléments contre lesquelles on peut
penser soi même celle qui est signé par
eux carlina race et ses amis me semble
avoir comme but comme plaisir
j'allais dire comme jouissance mais je
ne sais pas je vais me retrouver demain
matin la guerre civile alors
effectivement si on veut la guerre
civile il s'agit de distribuer des
postures de distribuer des rôles de
distribuer la méchanceté et de dire on
ne discute pas ceux qui discutent sont
d'ores et déjà des collaborateurs moi je
n'ai aucune envie de vivre dans sotc
dans cette société là d'autant plus que
je trouve que d'une manière générale et
très au delà de la question du rapport
entre les sexes la tension dans la
société est extrêmement forte
l'agressivité dans la société est
extrêmement forte et cette qualité
formidable qu'on appelle l'urbanité et
quelque chose qui s'est beaucoup pas
moins de riz au cours des dernières
années et je précise que
la réponse de karl une grâce à laquelle
vous faites allusion est disponible sur
le site internet france info on parlait
de l'urbanité jean baptiste émergents
qui est un garçon parfaitement turbin
figaro.fr nous a rejoint jean baptiste
qu'est ce qu'on en dit est ce que c'est
aussi urbain sur ceux sur les réseaux
sociaux que sur ce plateau le débat sur
ce sujet oui non comme souvent et même
en général c'est pas très urbain sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment sur twitter où
les communautés s'affrontent
ça fait à peu près 24 heures que les
mots volent que les insultes fusent
entre ces collectifs qui à la fois un
côté de collectif qui va soutenir à
catherine deneuve et sa tribune un autre
côté le collectif de caroline de haas
tout un ensemble de collectif autour de
karine de l'as qui sont comme un peu
plus virulent et plus mobilisés que du
côté de catherine n'a peut-être un gap
générationnel mais aussi un gap
idéologique
j'ai pris un premier tweet qui vient de
loubna qui dit qui se dit très déçu de
catherine deneuve beaucoup de fans qui
se disent un petit peu déçue ou alors
choqué de la prise de position de cette
femme qui avait pas énormément pris la
parole sur le sujet la politisation
d'acteurs est assez souvent choquant
ségolène royal elle qui est une actrice
politique trouve dommage que notre
grande catherine deneuve se joignent à
ce texte consternant pas mal de
personnalités politiques maliennes scapa
je crois n'a pas encore pris la parole
nous l'apprend draft l on ne sait pas la
militante féministe caroline de haas
elle est critique déjà naturellement
hier elle dit les femmes qui signe une
tribune dans le monde pour défendre le
droit d'agresser sexuellement les femmes
donc elle regrette et elle dit que avec
un peu d'ironie que 2018 s'annonce bien
vous pouvez un petit peu sentir qu'une
tribunal ait dégainé aujourd'hui dans
cette tribune l'a donc paru sur france
info elle dit que cette tribune est un
peu le collègue gênant des longues
fatiguant qui ne conçoivent pas ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est ce
qu'elle disait tout à l'heure au micro
et elle ajoute alors c'est un petit peu
long mais je trouve c'est important de
le dire nous avons le droit fondamental
de ne pas être insultées sifflet
agressée et violée nous avons le droit
fondamental de vivre nos vies en
sécurité en france aux états unis au
sénégal en thaïlande ou au brésil
et ce n'est pas aujourd'hui le cas et
effectivement elle internationalise un
petit peu le sujet
donc c'est une façon on prend une
réalité qui est inacceptable
la sulte l'agressivité la manifestation
physique de violence de et on transpose
ça comme si c'était de manière
permanente le type de relation
un garçon quel que soit son âge un homme
quel que soit son âge se propose
d'essayer d'envisager avec une
partenaire qu'il espère consentante ou
inversement mais enfin vous bien peu de
plaintes sur la violence des femmes
faites aux hommes bien qu'ils aient des
femmes qui battent leurs âmes c'est une
chose que j'ai découvert quand je
travaillais en psychiatrie et
quelquefois elles sont très violentes
mais c'est pas le sujet donc c'est à
partir du moment où on transforme toute
espèce de rapport de faire sa cour en un
rapport d'insultés de violences
récemment on a la réponse à sa question
est-ce que c'est acceptable
ben non mais la tribune de départ était
choc sa portée directement au physique
de beaucoup de personnes caroline de
haas et donc féliciter sur twitter
effectivement la communauté est un peu
plus mobilisés bravo pour cette réponse
ou faire un grand merci à une tribune
intelligente bravo et merci je tiens à
rajouter quand même que la tribune de
catherine deneuve avait été aussi
félicité pas trop sur twitter mais
beaucoup sur le site du monde sait ce
que relever tout à l'heure guillaume
beaucoup de mercy partout les
communautés s'affrontent comme
d'habitude beaucoup de polarisation le
seul point de différence c'est que
catherine deneuve et la grande catherine
et donc elle est connue dans le monde
entier est là donc on peut voir beaucoup
de tweets et beaucoup de médias du monde
entier qui relève justement cette
tribune là où caroline de haas n'existe
pas on a le times bbc mundo alors c'est
un espagnol peut être que guillaume
point de faire la traduction - je ne
parle calmement donc je vais parler du
zeit qui parle de la chao depuis
l'origine donc l'actrice catherine
deneuve qui alerte sur les femmes et les
conditions des femmes est donc le vrai
sujet il a va différence et si on peut
dire qu'il faut dire quelqu'un a gagné
ou perdu clairement caroline de haas a
perdu elle a gagné sur la mobilisation
en ligne sur twitter mais c'est assez
restreint au niveau mondial et
internationale la communauté des acteurs
qui avait déjà été sollicité reprend
essai 15-9 catherine catherine deneuve
packard de vidéos merci merci jean
baptiste émergents bienvenue à tous les
internautes qui se connectent bienvenus
notamment droitiste qui nous dit on ne
peut plus rien dire mais si chara mais
ici on peut dire les choses la preuve
c'est qu'on est là alexis lacroix
je ne pense pas tout à fait comme nos
amis eh ben je rejoins plutôt le point
de vue de guyane pour le coup je suis
évidemment le premier d'ailleurs on
l'avait je l'avais dit à votre micro
guillaume je me souviens avoir mis en
garde contre le haro sur weinstein
car effectivement il y a dans ses
processus là
si vous voulez des il ya toujours la
tentation de la chasse aux sorcières et
de la stigmatisation a priori je crois
qu'il faut savoir de quoi l'on parle
du coup on parle si on parle de la
liberté de draguer puisque c'est ce que
revendique à juste titre pour les hommes
elisabeth lévy évidemment que la bande
de millet etc ont raison évidemment
qu'on est entré dans un processus où il
faut faire attention que les mises en
cause du harcèlement ne débouche pas sur
un soupçon jeter a priori surtout
dragueur comme on dit vulgairement un
peu lourd mais je ne crois pas que les
féministes les plus engagés parle
essentiellement de cela et c'est pour ça
cher philippe que dans avec toute
l'amitié que j'ai pour vous je suis
légèrement en désaccord je crois que les
ministres les plus militantes
elle parle d'autre chose elle parle de
situation où le harcèlement prend des
formes physiques plus lourde c'est à
dire vraiment importune et donc je suis
déçu j'aime beaucoup et lisent avec les
vis et je pense qu'elles ajoutent à la
confusion de ces débats en disant je
plaide pour que la liberté du dragueur
d'importuner non il n'y a pas de liberté
du dragueur d'importuner si on est
attaché comme vous le dites cher
philippe à l'urbanité de la civilisation
française
on doit savoir qu'il ya des manières de
draguer qui ne sont pas acceptables et
qui ne sont pas défendables et je ne
crois pas que ce soit cédé comme le fait
marlène schiappa par exemple un
totalitarisme d'un nouveau style mais
orwelliens comme 10 pour nous effrayer
tous les néo réactionnaire de service
qui qui écrivent ici ou là je ne crois
pas que ce soit cédé à ça que de mettre
en garde contre les formes absolument
inopportune de drague
vous avez notamment dans les quartiers
où sévit un certain islamisme une
manière de parler aux femmes de toucher
les femmes même de les regarder qui est
inadmissible et donc mettre en cause
cette manière là franchement c'est pas
faire reculer la décence commune chère à
orwell s'est pas non plus toucher à
l'urbanité la civilisation française
c'est bien plutôt la renforcer alors par
ailleurs je suis d'accord avec vous
parce que caroline graffe carole
caroline de haas est une est unique
biolog étriqué mais elle a face à elle
elle a face à elle des gens qui sont
tout aussi idéologues et tout aussi
stupide je n'ai aucune admiration pour
les combattre catherine millet
je pense si vous voulez qu'on a le droit
d'étudier comment vous dire on a le
droit de défendre la soumission
masochiste mais on ne peut pas confondre
on ne peut pas confondre des choses
absolument privées avec des engagements
sur des questions aussi délicates et
donc je ne faisait absolument pas miens
le cette tribune du les positions
affirmées par cette tribune du monde
je pense qu'elle est parfaitement
excessive et qu'elle ajoute dans sa
confusion à une sorte de confusion
générale des esprits en fait on a à
faire à mon avis et là je rejoins
aiguillonne à d'opposition totalement
caricatural et au clash pardon de le
dire comme ça et au clash de 2,1 visite
tout est en tout cas
donc voila vous n'êtes ni l'un des neuf
ni de as non je veux juste y amasser
vous pensé quand même pas catherine
deneuve et les signataires de sa de son
texte défendent ce que vous fustigez
toute la leur il ya une ambiguïté de
canton quand elisabeth lévy que j'aime
beaucoup
oulala 12h10 la liberté pour les
dragueurs d'un portugais non je suis
désolé je suis désolé l'a signée par sa
réalisation la civilisation c'est pas la
guerre
juste un mot pour dire qu' il faut quand
même noter que à cette tribune de
catherine deneuve et décider des autres
signataires
peut-être faudrait-il ajouter un certain
nombre de réactions au licenciement d'un
présentateur de jeu télévisé qui
lui-même les texans dans le genre grosse
blague lourde quand on pensait même que
plus personne ne faisait enfin cette
vaut vraiment et ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas c'est pas de prendre parti sur
cette affaire c'est de voir que dans
cette affaire là comme dans l'autre il
ya un dans la société un mouvement de
gens qui disent attention à la rue
attention oui c'est ça à la
multiplication des règles j'ai pensé à
un truc c'est une seule phrase du
dialogue des carmélites
j'ai toujours trouvé très ou la mère
supérieure dit à la jeune blanche de la
force qui voudraient est religieuse mais
qui probablement n'a pas ce qu'il faut
pour elle la jeune blanche lui dit mais
ma mère la règle m'y aidera et la mère
supérieure lui dit mon fils c'est pas la
règle qui nous garde c'est nous qui
garde on arrête
merci denis tillinac
je veux juste jeu avant je vous passe la
parole je salue les très nombreux
internautes qui nous suivent notamment
sur sur facebook lulu jeannette
populiste rachid et je vous cite cette
intervention intéressant de jlr qui nous
dit les gens croient que les féministes
veulent interdire tout contact entre les
hommes et les femmes dans la rue non ils
veulent juste que les hommes comprennent
que non ça veut dire non et c'est tout
on peut draguer mais il faut respecter
la vie des femmes quand elle dit non
denis c'est pas facile de savoie a
priori si un dragueur et il est
intentionnés normes ci devient important
pas on sait qu'après donc vous bien
qu'il faut bien qu'ils tentent quelque
chose et qui va évaluer si quelque chose
c'est trop ou tout juste assez ou pas ou
est pas le ca non le fond du problème
derrière tout cela et bien qu'ils
allaient bien que ces tribunes parce que
bon derrière un soit disant combat
féministe pour l'émancipation de la
femme qui a eu toute sa légitimité
depuis deux siècles qui existe on a des
radicaliser idéologues qui veulent à
nier l'altérité du masculin du féminin
du yo-yo ready de l'animus de l'animal
ces relations dans l'animus et animale
dans notre civilisation ça a donné
l'amour courtois s'adonner à quarts du
temps de s'adonner le romantisme
ça donnait tout une tout un jeu subtil
délicat littéraires musicales pictural
toute notre culture a été construite sur
les relations de séduction sur un
éternel féminin qui est la femme
concrète avec ses droites sommet qui est
quelque chose qui la dépasse quelque
chose de plus inaccessibles quelque
chose qui est tissée par le plus beau de
notre imaginaire c'est tout ça que sont
en train de nier quelques un cahier donc
ils étaient ils étaient bien que des
frémissements ça je rappelle quand même
que catherine millet au catherine robbe
grillet vingt dix films en effet s'il
m'en passer pour des carmélites
dir bon donc non c'est alors le débat le
débat est tronqué parce que l'on peut
personnes descendent le viol la violence
faite aux femmes les femmes qui se font
tabasser tous les jours ça c'est un
combat légitime
bon mais le combat pour vouloir
absolument neutraliser banaliser le
masculin et féminin pour fabriquer des
femmes qui ne seront plus que des hommes
au féminin ben ce combat est il légitime
nous va nous amène tout droit dans le
meilleur des mondes d'huxley et ça j'en
veux aucun bris donc bravo pour cette va
bien que je prends une passion pour 2,9
préfère quand même d'autres qui dans un
autre combat il ya quelques années
auprès d'autres positions dionne vous
aurez le dernier mot
en fait ce que ce que vous dites denier
est tout à fait pour moi juste et me
renvoie à tout un imaginaire qui me
plaît beaucoup mais je crois que
l'arrivée des écrans au milieu des gens
là les relations qui se passent par
internet les relations amoureuses les le
manque de relief de ce type de dialogue
sur une fraude par internet par des
films et les relations qui sont à trèves
la violence de ses relations la à
travers les images choquantes les apps
tout ça un peu fait voler déjà un peu en
éclats cet aspect carte du tendre
imaginaire et tranquille approche
graphique située à l'iphone restitue
faut le réinventer heureusement il reste
la raison y a pas de relation d'amour
sur internet mais y'a des relations de
violence violence est là pour le
réveillon de l'espèce de libération de
ce qui peut y avoir de plus brutale et
de plus agressifs à travers un
vocabulaire
non c'est pas nous c'est ce qui est
nouveau c'est le moyen et voilà et
d'ailleurs il ya un internet qui nous
dit sur le tchad figaro monsieur
tillinac la civilisation française ne
suppose t elle pas une drague physique
ou en tout cas un contact réel entre
entre les personnes ça c'est certain
18 ans étaient les premières chansons de
johnny hallyday
tout à fait tendre bien trop timides ou
12 ces violences
on est des slows qu'est ce que c'est
parce que sinon amim sexuelle qui
faisait qu'au bout d'une seconde et
demie des danses
je me réveille avec la dame dans un lieu
à vie c'était un contact physique
on est des bons la drague soit arrêté si
j'avais collé la fille contre un sofa
avril son gré on les pose d'un beignet
pour la sauter non mais pas soyons qu'à
la drague là le harcèlement voulais lui
dire on pourrait vous pourrez pas les
faire dodo dans ma chambre gentiment
comme ça est ce que ces bleus non j'ai
pas dis que ça mange ça marchait pas
mais est ce que c'était de la brasse
est-ce que tu étais de la drague
inopportune est ce que c'était de la
violence et des bons et des jeux comme
ça
la société notre civilisation les a
inventés la situation chinoise en
inventer d'autres la note ça passe par
la séduction
donc ça passe par ya un moment où il ya
un peu il ya un peu d'interdît un peu de
transgression alors c'est pas qu'elle
soit bonne pour qu'elle soit délicate
c'est un jeu dans lequel il ya des
femmes qui disent non parce que c'est
une façon de dire oui
d'autres c'est un vraiment bon mais on
comprend on voit maire a saisi mon corps
était quand même dans cette tribune
parce que le bon sens et voilà on va on
va réduire que d'autres jeunes confrères
soient partis parce que je peux prévoir
ce qu'on va voir sur twitter à partir de
ce qu'on vient entend par exemple qui va
je vois très bien comment on va découper
une phrase de denis pour la mède sur
twitter et expliqué qu'il a suscité
oui il faut l'accepter voilà parce qu'il
ya effectivement beaucoup de de violence
et de brutalité sur ce sujet sur
internet
il ya aussi au point de vue où on cite
l'animus l'anima et bernanos pour
essayer d'élever un peu le débat